there and the wild builds are there
people are playing on PC like what's
happening we've done it for ages if my
stuff goes out there it goes out there
whatever reason I as much as I dislike
it so that's the ethics of it I think
the the you know I I've been quite vocal
even though people misinterpret it what
what I say I say I believe in the Xbox
tax generally because of Microsoft's
performance and media's Affinity with
PlayStation and you know not trying to
get burned with them there's good and
bad there but at the moment that I was
saying that I was like just calm it down
let's not play the victim here this
happened and then I watched the the
media have this circus with the ethics
and this complete absolute hypocrisy cuz
that's the use the word it is hypocrisy